la principal organización de pueblos
indígenas de ecuador conaie celebro la
decisión judicial que dejó en libertad
condicional a su presidente leonidas iza
un dictamen que llegó en la noche del
martes al miércoles el líder indígena
había sido detenido debido a su supuesto
papel en la paralización de los
servicios públicos el bloqueo de una
carretera en el contexto de un paro
contra el gobierno de guillermo lasso el
área esto provocó la indignación de su
comunidad que denunció una detención
arbitraria e hizo un llamado a la
radicalización de las protestas
provocando enfrentamientos con la fuerza
pública los indígenas rechazan las
políticas económicas del presidente
guillermo lasso denunciando el
encarecimiento de los productos básicos
en el país andino la inflación la falta
de empleo y el alto precio de los
combustibles nosotros no estamos
haciendo ningún daño más bien nosotros
necesitamos la vida el diálogo
entonces yo le digo al señor presidente
que ya es hora de dialogar la su por su
parte reiteró su intención de dialogar
pero según la conaie ninguna de las
conversaciones previas han cumplido sus
reclamos
la magistrada paula de bonn consideró
lícita la detención de leonidas iza que
aunque queda libre no podrá salir del
país y tendrá que presentarse ante la
fiscalía los miércoles y viernes en
horarios laborales